bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette seconde vidéo dédiée à
Ant-Man cantumania alors je ne sais pas
trop comment s'appelle ras cette vidéo
car en fait j'aimerais que l'on parle de
kangle conquérant de manière assez
générale pour justement appréhender
l'avenir du MCU ce qu'il pourrait se
passer etc etc et forcément bah aussi
parler de la scène Paul générique le
film Ant-Man quantumania a reçu
énormément de critiques et à juste titre
par moment je ne suis pas un expert du
cinéma donc je ne m'attarderai pas trop
là dessus en revanche il y a eu des
critiques sur le personnage de Kang le
conquérant et ça j'aimerais vous en
parler car justement bah j'ai les
capacités de le faire quand le
Conquérant est des pins comme le nouveau
Thanos et c'est le cas Nathaniel
Richards le vrai nom de Kang ainsi que
ses nombreuses identités ont pour but de
devenir la nouvelle menace centrale du
MCU de la saga du multivers pourtant
beaucoup sont in et je peux le
comprendre car le Kang dantman
quantumania est loin très très loin
d'être au niveau de Thanos on dirait un
méchant bas de gamme il s'est fait
déglinguer par Ant-Man et des fourmis
bref etc etc mais en réalité c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait normal et
plausible je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi pour moi dans Ant-Man
quantumania le Kang que nous a proposé
Marvel et parfait si l'on reprend les
comics d'origine kangle conquérant est à
la base qu'un simple humain du nom de
Nathaniel Richards il est un
scientifique du 31ème siècle avant tout
expert de la robotique lassé de son
époque c'est après avoir appréhendé le
voyage dans le temps et découvert
plusieurs époques qui est l'atterrira au
41ème siècle par erreur la fameuse r où
il va devenir Kang le Conquérant grâce à
la technologie futuriste de l'humanité
sauf que c'est là qu'il faut qu'on parle
quand Nathaniel va prendre l'identité de
Kang le conquérant et bien en fait c'est
le moment où il va prendre la la grosse
tête là c'est le moment où il va devenir
extrêmement ambitieux et très arrogant
ce dernier va effectuer d'innombrables
voyages temporels pour asservir l'année
x régné sur la dimension machin détruire
l'univers truc etc etc mais ce qu'il ne
sait pas et on en a déjà beaucoup parlé
mais chacun de ces voyages ont en fait
créer une réalité divergente qui va
donner naissance à un autre Kang et vu
que c'est Kang voyage aussi dans le
temps bah il donne eux aussi naissance à
d'autres Kangs et ainsi de suite dans le
multivers Nathaniel Richards et la
personne qui a créé le plus grand nombre
d'événements Nexus donnant donc par
conséquent naissance à des univers
alternatifs et c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir dans l'histoire des comics les
Avengers affront Kang à de multiples
mais vraiment de multiples reprises et
les combats se termineront toujours sur
la défaite de ce dernier voire même par
moment la mort mais du coup si quand est
mort comment cela se fait-il que les
Avengers l'auraient affrontent encore et
encore et en plus de cela Kang et
normalement connoté surpuissant voyageur
temporel etc donc comment cela se
fait-il qu'ils perdent en fait et bien
c'est là la particularité sans le savoir
les Avengers affront en réalité des
gangs divergents qui ont vécu
similairement la même histoire que leur
variantes à chaque combat nous serons en
fait face à un Kang différent de 1964
jusqu'en 1986 on croira que les Avengers
se combattront le même antagoniste alors
que ce n'est pas le cas tous ne seront
que des variants et pire que ça on va
casser un mythe mais l'identité générale
de kangle conquérant n'est pas si
puissante que l'on pourrait le penser je
m'explique comme on le disais plutôt le
personnage n'est qu'un simple humain il
n'est qu'un scientifique nous sommes
très loin mais alors très loin d'un
Thanos qui est originaire de la planète
titan qui en plus de ça descend d'une
grande famille d'éternel rajouter à ça
le fait que thano possède le gène
déviant qui le encore plus fort sans
oublier également le gant de l'infini
avec les pierres Thanos est une
véritable force brute et d'ailleurs dans
les comics il est également le champion
de la mort un élucosmique choisi par la
mort elle-même on est très loin de tout
ça c'est limite incomparable avec Kang
le conquérant et en plus de ça il faut
parler de l'essence même du personnage
de kangle conquérant le dictateur est un
véritable être imparfait il est imbul
lui-même il est très très colérique il
est arrogant etc etc la quasi totalité
de toutes ces défaites dans les comics
seront causées à cause de ça à cause de
ces émotions à cause de lui-même
prenons sa toute première apparition
dans le comics Avengers numéro 8 Kang
débarque au 20e siècle pour asservir la
temporalité des Avengers en deux temps
trois mouvements il va ridiculiser
l'équipe de super-héros grâce à sa
technologie beaucoup trop futuriste pour
l'heure actuelle et ce n'est pas une
blague je ne suis pas du tout en train
de minimiser la situation Kang va
véritablement mettre à genoux les
Avengers et les emprisonner dans son
vaisseau à tel point que le gouvernement
américain sera obligé d'aller pour
parler avec lui et vous savez comment il
va perdre un groupe d'adolescents
n'acceptera pas que Kang devienne leur
nouveau souverain du coup ils vont faire
croire aux conquérants qu'ils veulent
devenir ces subordonnés Kong leur
demandera alors d'aller chercher une
sorte d'outil à lui dans le vaisseau et
pouf ils vont libérer les Avengers qui
vont prendre le Conquérant par surprise
et le faire fuir le Conquérant dont la
technologie est complètement
inimaginable pour le 20e siècle a perdu
parce qu'il était trop naïf et qu'il a
fait confiance à un groupe d'adolescents
c'est un peu
quand même Kang en fait un véritable
pouvoir mais à chaque fois il perd à
cause de ses émotions comics numéro 24
des Avengers Kang souhaite conquérir une
petite dimension avec son armée il va
finalement tomber amoureux de la
princesse ravona et se retourner contre
ses propres soldats qui sont en mode bah
tu fais quoi c'est pas du tout le plan
on a dit pas de pitié et au final bah la
princesse va mourir comics 71 toujours
dans la saga Avengers un être suprême
appelé le grand maître des galaxies va
conférer au choix à kangle conquérant le
pouvoir total de la vie ou de la mort
pour une action ça bien aimé ravona
étant décédé on se doute qu'il va
choisir le pouvoir de la vie pour la
réanimer c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il
souhaite au début du comics et bien non
un but de lui-même est colérique il va
choisir le pouvoir de la mort pour tuer
les Avengers qui en plus vont réussir
finalement à déjouer le plan de Kang et
au final bah le Conquérant finira tout
seul dans son vaisseau avec les Avengers
sans vie et ravona toujours morte comics
141 un combat dans le début des années
1920 va se déclencher entre Thor et
kangle conquérant l'antagoniste a les
moyens de tuer Torres il l'a même
ridiculisé dans le tout premier comics
Avengers mais il n'arrivera pas à en
venir à bout et au final dans un excès
de colère Kang va augmenter la puissance
de son armure au maximum ce qui va le
désintégrer Kang s'est tué tout seul
bref je pense que vous voyez où je veux
en venir mais Kang est un être
complètement imparfait qui se laisse
extrêmement guider par ses émotions et
justement si on reprend Ant-Man
quantumania et bien Marvel a en fait
respecté totalement la vibe des comics
nous sommes face à un kangle conquérant
que l'on pense
ultime alors qu'en fait pas du tout tout
comme dans les comics en fait il est
arrogant un but lui-même et beaucoup
trop ambitieux
ce Kang comme les batailles qui nous
sont proposées dans les comics se fera
avoir par des êtres inférieurs à sa
puissance on l'a il maîtrise moque par
le biais d'un bouton il a asservi
Ant-Man en deux secondes il détruit la
rébellion à lui tout seul mais voilà il
est colérique aveuglé par sa puissance
et sa supériorité dans le multivers et
se fera battre exactement comme dans les
comics bon du coup on a bien cassé la
réputation de Kang le Conquérant comment
du coup le rendre incroyable pour
l'avenir du MCU comment faire succéder
le personnage à Thanos tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que l'on sait concernant Kang
par rapport à la saga du multivers le
personnage aura son film dédié à la fin
de la fascisse nous aurons une véritable
montée en puissance ainsi qu'une
conclusion avec Avengers the candynasty
sans oublier évidemment Avengers Secret
Wars étant le nouveau successeur de
Thanos le nouveau vilain ultime de la
saga et bien pareil il faut l'introduire
petit à petit à plusieurs reprises et
comme déclaré par les scénaristes de
Marvel il n'y a pas une histoire qui ne
sera pas liée à Kang en fait le truc
c'est qu'avec Thanos ils l'ont utilisé
petit à petit en mode il y a un méchant
dans l'ombre qui prépare un grand plan
etc et après on a l'apogée du personnage
avec Infinity War et endgame là avec
Kang c'est le même principe mais fait
différemment car ce n'est pas le même
personnage et la même essence tout comme
dans les comics on en a déjà parlé mais
je pense et c'est même obligé qu'ils
introduisent plusieurs fois le
personnage à travers plusieurs films
l'univers du MCU se développe avec ses
héros ces histoires etc et en même temps
on va nous ramener Kang ces autres
identités à chaque fois là on a eu une
première version de Kang avec Ant-Man
quantumania la scène post générique nous
a révélé qu'il existait un nombre
incalculable d'autres variants de Kang
et en plus ils ont révélé au spectateur
qu'il y avait d'autres
identités comme ramatout ou encore
Immortus
il y a un exemple d'ailleurs qui est
intéressant et qui peut t'appuyer tout
ça nous savons que les Quatre
Fantastiques auront leur film dédiés au
début de la fassise de Marvel et comme
dévoilée par les scénaristes il y a de
grandes chances que ce dernier soit lui
aussi relié à Kango conquérant et ses
variantes sachant que dans les comics
les Quatre Fantastiques ont déjà
confronté à ramatoutes qui étaient l'un
de leurs plus grands ennemis alors début
et bien ce serait l'occasion d'avoir
pourquoi pas un film introduisant cette
identité pour mieux comprendre Kang et
tiser Avengers the candynastie de la
même manière que Thanos apparaissait de
temps en temps jusqu'à son arrivée dans
Infinity war il y a moyen de faire ça
avec énormément d'oeuvres futures du MCU
Deadpool 3 par exemple avec le
changement d’univers les voyages dans le
temps etc il y a moyen de ramener Kang
Docteur Strange in the Multiverse
Madness Red Richards possède une
technologie similaire à kangle
conquérant dans Ant-Man quantumania est
bon Kang s'appelle Nathaniel Richards
monsieur fantastique c'est ridri Charles
voilà je pense que vous avez compris
qu'il y avait un petit lien de parenté
entre les deux Dr Strange 2 a aussi
ramené le concept d'incursion nous avons
le sinister strange dont l'univers a été
détruit par une incursion il y a de
fortes chances que ce soit aussi relié à
Kang et ses variants bref sans oublier
la série Loki qui va étoffer ainsi
qu'Explorer l'essence et les concepts
derrière quand le Conquérant quantumania
nous a introduit Victor time Lee et il y
aura certainement d'autres
identités comme on en parlait histoire
qu'on apprenne du nouvel antagoniste et
qu'on comprenne comment il fonctionne
pour les non lecteurs de comics et là
vous allez me dire ouais non c'est bien
tout ça ok on aura du teasing ok on aura
des explications mais bon Kang ne
m'inspire rien Thanos c'était un vrai
bon vilain avec de vrais motivations
entendable là quand on dirait juste un
méchant qui veut faire le mal pour faire
le mal et bien justement c'est là où on
va pouvoir un peu théoriser et je vais
essayer de vous démontrer l'unicité du
personnage Thanos c'est clair c'était un
vilain de fou pour la première apogée de
Marvel il y avait ce délire de
ressources limitées avec la
surpopulation d'être vivant dans
l'univers tuer la moitié de l'existence
permet effectivement de laisser
l'univers respirer un peu plus car moins
de consommateurs et voilà bref il y
avait une vraie problématique ce qui
pêche avec Thanos et ce qui en faisait
un vrai vilain c'était plutôt sa méthode
Thanos se prenait pour un Dieu il se
sentait investi d'une mission et sa
morale était très discutable ce n'est
pas pour rien qu'il était appelé le
Titan fou maintenant concernant Kang
nous le savons la nouvelle saga va
aboutir sur une gigantesque guerre
multiverselle avec des incursions de
partout comme dans l'événement Secret
Wars et cela se terminera avec
l'effondrement du multivers cela a été
tisé dans Loki cela a été utilisé
également dans quantumania ou Kang nous
dit qu'il a vu le futur etc bref on sait
vers quoi on se dirige mais justement
c'est là-dessus que l'on doit se
concentrer pour voir quels seront les
thématiques importantes du futur de
Marvel et comment justement ces derniers
vont faire resur dire la complexité du
personnage de Kan déjà reprenons la base
d'une incursion une incursion c'est
quand deux univers entrent en collision
aboutissant sur la destruction totale de
ces derniers ce qui veut dire que des
centaines de milliards d'êtres vivants
qui n'ont rien demandé vont mourir
malheureusement à notre connaissance de
par les comics il n'y a pas de solution
contre les incursions la seule chose que
nous pouvons faire c'est détruire
l'univers avec lequel on va entrer en
collision pour assurer sa survie rien
qu'avec ceci nous avons déjà une belle
problématique le multivers est quelque
chose de naturel il existe plusieurs
réalités alternatives avec des êtres
vivants qui vivent leur petite vie mais
les incursions viennent chambouler tout
ça et créer un gigantesque génocide
comme dans l'événement Secret Wars nous
ferons face à une véritable déchirure
devons-nous tuer des innocents pour
assurer notre survie ou devons-nous
laisser l'ordre naturel faire les choses
et par rapport à tout ceci il faut
ramener Kang et ses vari possède un rôle
très précis et même crucial dans cette
histoire car en fait ils sont la cause
des incursions et de la guerre
multiverselle mais de l'autre côté ils
sont aussi la solution comme expliqué de
par les comics Nathaniel Richards
devenus Kang et celui qui a donné le
plus naissance à des Nexus des points
dans le temps qui ont créé des réalités
alternatives et par conséquent la
naissance d'autres Kangs comme expliqué
dans Loki les variants de Nathaniel dans
le MCU ont fait la découverte que le
multivers existait et par le biais de
leur technologie ont commencé à se
contacter et partager leur savoir pour
améliorer les univers des uns et des
autres malheureusement pas tous les
variants étaient bienveillants et pour
certains d'autres univers signifiait
d'autres mondes à conquérir rien qu'avec
ceci nous avons en fait la cause et la
solution Daniel Richards et l'expert
ultime du multivers et de son
fonctionnement beaucoup de variants du
personnage se sont réunis ce sont
établis dans le temps et partout dans le
multivers ils ont trafiqué les flux
temporelles bâti un véritable monument
où ils ont le contrôle de ce dernier
mais de l'autre côté nous avons des
variants rebelles qui veulent tout
détruire et tout conquérir ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que Nathaniel
tout comme dans les comics de par ses
voyages et ses expériences à en fait
donner lui-même naissance au futur
effondrement du multivers il a engendré
lui et ses variants de nombreux Nexus
qui donnent naissance à d'autres
réalités qui du coup donnent naissance à
d'autres combles puis de l'autre côté vu
que l'effondrement sera causé par des
variants de lui-même créé par sa faute
et bien celui peut résoudre ce problème
est-ce que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire pour être plus clair reprenons un
peu les comics déjà même si Kang est un
ennemi des Avengers il est capable de
s'allier à eux et pourquoi cela et bien
tout simplement car les Avengers ne sont
pas de véritables ennemis pour Kang son
véritable adversaire c'est lui-même je
vous conseille de lire Avengers Forever
mais quand Kang va prendre conscience de
l'existence de ces autres lui-même et
qu'en plus de cela il est guidé
inconsciemment par son identité future
les Avengers seront mis au second plan
ce ne seront même plus les ennemis de
Kang ce dernier voudra seulement se
confronter avec ses autres lui ainsi que
son lui du futur et en plus de cela pour
celles et ceux qui ne savent pas mais
l'événement the kangynastie existe dans
les comics et cela traduit complètement
vers quoi on se tourne après tout le
prochain film Avengers porte ce titre
donc vous doutez bien que Marvel va
adapter ce moment pour faire simple nous
sommes face aux véritables Kang le
Conquérant libéré de son destin
accompagné de son fils Marcus prenant
l'identité de Scarlett centurion les
deux personnages vont voyager jusqu'à
l'air du 21e siècle non pas pour
combattre les Avengers mais pour leur
proposer leur aide Kang va expliquer
qu'un futur très macabre va anéantir
l'humanité et qu'étant donné qu'il est
le célèbre voyageur temporel un
véritable maître du temps celui peut
éviter les futurs menaces de l'humanité
il connaît lui-même le futur bon au
final tout ce cirque était bien
évidemment une manipulation de Kangs
pour prendre le contrôle de la terre et
sincèrement cet événement mérite
clairement pour moi d'être adapté en
film en fait quand a joué sur un plan
dont il est excellent la gestion de la
guerre et la politique il a fait croire
à l'humanité tout entière que pour
éviter les possibles futurs macabre la
terre devait se ranger derrière lui et
que tous ceux qui se battraient à ses
côtés auraient une place de choix dans
son armée bien évidemment c'est quelque
chose qui va créer l'anarchie totale sur
la planète énormément de gens se
rangeront derrière Kang tandis que
d'autres comme les Avengers s'y
opposeront Kang va faire tomber les pays
un à un et en commençant par la France
et oui notre pays va se faire détruire
par Kang en tout premier quel honneur
les Avengers seront répartis dans le
monde entier pour faire face à toutes
les menaces combattre les vilains qui
ont rejoint Kang comme atuma accompagné
des Atlantes ou encore la race des
déviants qui sont désormais alliés aussi
à Kang sans oublier l'immense armée du
conquérant venant du 41e siècle Kang va
saccager la terre accompagner de son
fils Marcus obligeant la reddition
complète du monde et petit détail que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup c'est que Kang
a tellement investi le temps et du coup
l'histoire qu'il sait tout il connaît
tout il est partout par exemple à un
moment donné les États-Unis lanceront un
ultimatum ou si la situation ne se règle
pas très vite ils enverront des
sentinelles des sortes d'immenses robots
capables de tout détruire sauf que Kang
a bien évidemment tout prévu avec ses
voyages dans le temps si les États-Unis
ont pu obtenir des robots si avancés et
expérimentés et bien c'est parce qu'en
réalité Kang qui est un expert de la
robotique investi dans le passé sous
l'identité de Victor timely et grâce à
son savoir et bien c'est lui qui a
permis aux États-Unis de se développer
sur ce plan car il a apporté son savoir
dans le passé et du coup bien évidemment
il va retourner les sentinelles contre
ses créateurs bref au final dans
l'événement de la dynastie de la langue
les Avengers réussiront à défaire leur
nouveau souverain après de nombreuses
batailles et malgré les millions de
morts causés par le conquérant mais
avant de se faire emprisonner et tuer
Kang va sauver son fils Marcus pour que
ce dernier reprenne ce qu'il a bâtit car
il est son dignité néanmoins Marcus va
finalement revenir pour sauver son père
ce qui n'était pas du tout prévu par
Kang dont les ordres étaient que Marcus
devait fuir et reprendre l'empire de son
père et voyant ça comme une trahison
Kang va tuer Marcus et nous révéler
qu'il s'agissait en réalité de son 23e
fils et c'est pour une adaptation du MCU
ce qu'il faut retenir de la dynastie de
Kang c'est le fait que le personnage
souhaite prendre le contrôle de la terre
pour en devenir son fervent défenseur
contre un futur très macabre bien
évidemment on ressent clairement l'idée
de Kang arrive prend le contrôle de la
terre Avengers
fait la guerre contre les autres
lui-même des autres univers engendrant
des incursions de partout et de la
destruction des mondes bref c'est un
véritable Alpha et Oméga Kang donne
naissance à beaucoup de réalité et au
final c'est lui qui va les détruire
comme le dit celui qui demeure au moment
de la guerre multiverselle chaque angle
voulait protéger son univers et Annie
les celui des autres au moment de la
guerre multiders un univers signifie en
fait la base de kangle conquérant et
chacun défendra sa base sa réalité face
à celle des autres ce qui veut dire du
coup que Kang est également la solution
au problème connaissant le futur étant
celui qui a causé tous ses soucis étant
établi dans l'histoire de l'humanité à
cause de ses voyages et sachant comment
fonctionne le multivers et ses autres
lui-même il est en réalité vital pour la
survie d'un univers qu'il y est un Kang
affilié à ce dernier Kang est une menace
pour les autres univers mais il est par
conséquent et par logique le plus
fervent défenseur du sien Kang sera à la
fois un ennemi et un allié les Avengers
devront combattre à ses côtés pour
connaître toute l'histoire et avoir les
clés pour s'en sortir et devront
combattre les variants de Kang pour
assurer leur propre survie néanmoins il
reste quelque chose de taille que nous
avons mis de côté depuis le début de la
vidéo comme je vous disais au tout début
je voulais que dans cette vidéo on parle
de kangle conquérant de manière assez
générale après quantumania pour un peu
explorer son essence ses concepts etc
bref parler de tout ce qu'apporter
Ant-Man cantumania quoi mais la
véritable réponse a comment Kang peut
devenir le nouveau méchant
ultime de la saga du multivers et bien
c'est clair que c'est pour moi
l'avènement du prime Kang
le Kang élu et principal différent de
tous les autres et qui va permettre
l'aboutissement de tout je vous donne
donc rendez-vous dans la prochaine vidéo
pour vous proposer la théorie ultime
permettant d'expliquer l'entièreté de la
saga du multivers ainsi que comment va
se dérouler Avengers the candynastie et
Avengers Secret Wars
[Musique]
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et j'espère de tout cœur qu'elle vous
aura plu vous le savez nous avons
atteint les 100 000 abonnés merci
beaucoup et du coup bah j'ai longuement
réfléchi à ce que nous devrions faire
pour fêter cette occasion j'ai pensé à
plein d'idées de vidéos des trucs un peu
plus farfelus etc et de l'autre côté bah
j'avais besoin que Ant-Man quantumania
sorte parce que c'est bah le premier
film de la phase 5 qui était censé nous
annoncer plein de choses pour
candynastie etc j'avais besoin également
de poser certaines bases avec notamment
cette vidéo et désormais je pense mettre
décidé je pense que je vais vous
proposer une belle vidéo complète avec
ma vision entière de comment je vois les
choses de dans l'avenir du MCU etc je
vais vraiment essayer de vous faire un
truc propre un truc qui vous hype etc et
je pense que c'est la plus belle des
manières pour fêter les 100 000 abonnés
qu'on a eu juste au moment de la
transition vers la face 5 bref n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner n'oubliez pas
laisser un petit pouce bleu et un petit
commentaire tout ça c'est très important
que le Lionel heart soit avec vous les
amis c'était Targot rock allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]